hello everyone and so we reached the end
of the world bullets championship in the
end for those of you who haven't seen at
Magnus Carlsen won the entire event and
he wanted to watch two whole points
ahead of the field with fifteen and a
half points
Sergey Kerrigan was second with 13 and a
half points and okay some of you might
say well what are you talking about this
here is integrant Petrosyan but this is
Tigran Ivanovich petrosyan a 33 year old
chess grandmaster from Armenia also
sharing the same country as the famous
Steven Martin which petrosyan Tigran
here had his highest rating was
somewhere around 26 70 or 75 maybe not
yet in the top elite but definitely on
the right path here he faces Magnus
Carlsen this is I believe around 17 and
he has the white pieces so let's see
this game and I've seen the interview
with Magnus Carlsen after the entire
event he said that he was pretty lucky
in pretty much every game yesterday he
said he was lost in every game yesterday
but saying you were lucky it's something
mikhail tal often used to say in chess a
lock favors the strong so whenever you
lose the game against the stronger
opponent you might have been in a better
position but the reason your opponent
the beat you isn't because he was lucky
it's because he's just better that's the
sad truth and I myself always you know
often said that I had such a great
position against the player 2200 or 30
300 points he above me but in the end he
won because he's a stronger player and
such is the case with Magnus Carlsen he
won because he's the stronger player he
wasn't lucky but okay let's get back to
this game we have Knight to f3 by Tigran
Ivanovich petrosyan and c5 by Carlsen
it's do the reti opening the Sicilian
invitation and we have g3
g6 Bishop to g2 and Bishop to g7 take
Petrosyan castles and Knight to c6 by
Carlsen we have E for D 6 and D 3 e 5 C
3 and the knight the g2 is
a three by Petrosyan car sandcastles and
we have B for across the place a six
we have Knight bTW - Bishop to e6 and
Knight to g5 now Bishop to d7 by Carson
and not allowing the knight to be
exchanged for the bishop and now Knight
to c4 and here Tigran Petrosian is
preparing something devious h6 is played
by Carlson and this isn't the most
precise move here
Petrosyan actually had a great chance to
sacrifice a piece rather Petros indeed
sacrifice a piece but he didn't
sacrifice it in a way that he should
have sacrificed it the best move here is
Knight characters on f7 after rook
captures knife captures on b6 so we
already grabbed two points for the piece
and you completely messed up a black's
pawn structure after character son
before something before and they capture
some before rook moves Queen to b3 check
King moves and now you capture on b7
after the Queen moves depends depends on
where the Queen will move you can either
go to d6 or c5 White has so much
compensation for this piece it's three
points and much better positioned this
would have been great for Tigran
Petrosian
but after h6 Petros and decided to play
Knight captures on d6 immediately cousin
grab the piece H capture some g5 and we
have night capture some b7 this does
come with a temple on the Queen we have
Queen to c8 and now Knight captures on
c5 so similar position but black's pawn
structure isn't nearly as ruined as it
would have been if he played Knight
captures on f7 as I've showed previously
but okay g4 by Carlsen as the g5 pawn
was attacked we have F Bishop Bishop to
g5 rook to e8 adding protection to the
knight and his seven also developing the
rook and here white does have a couple
of options he could go f3 to either
break this structure open and release
his rook on the open F file
rook to c1 is an option but he plays
Queen to b3 and Queen to b3 in this
variation doesn't really give Petrosyan
that much
Knight to d8 by Carlsen we have Bishop
to e3 and now Knights the east
rook F 2 D 1 and we have night captures
on e5 Bishop captures on e5 and Bishop
to e6 would a temple on the Queen Queen
to a4 with Knight to c6 now and d4
Bishop captures sorry Bishop to c4 d5
now at night the b8 and the bishop to f1
but she captures rook captures and
Knight to d7 attacking the bishop on c5
of course Petrosyan doesn't want to
exchange Addison ruin his pawn structure
he plays Bishop to e3 and we have Knight
to f6
of course the c3 pawn isn't hanging you
can capture it your night across since
night on d7 is also hanging so Knight to
f6 we have Queen back to b3 and now
Knight captures on e4 and c4 and the
patron is still down a piece but this
beautiful pawn chain here on the Queen
side is surely compensation enough
especially in a blitz game Queen to f5
by Carlsen we have worked to c1 and
Bishop to f6 c5 now now Dignan lavona
which patrols and has right idea you
have a lot of passed pawns please push
them came to g7 by Carlsen f3 now Knight
to g5 Bishop captures Bishop captures
and rooks e2 e1 we have G captures on f3
recaptures on f3 and Queen back to d7
and d6 and now these pawns are really
looking looking good if if petrosyan
could somehow support these pawns to
continue pushing forward it would be
really great for him but Carlsen
immediately jumps into the contract he
plays e4 this comes up with an attack on
the rock on f3 Quintus III check by
Petrosyan
cross and moves the King back in g8 and
now rook to F to cross and immediately
he doesn't give Petrosyan a single
chance to push c6 we had III attacking
the rook on f2 and here
rook F 2 e 2 would definitely be a more
resilient move
patrols and played rook to f3 and this
allows Carson a bit more counter play he
plays Queen to c6
this blocks the C pawn from it
dancing to c6 and also it comes with a
temple on this unfortunate rock on f3
so King g2 defending this isn't I mean
this is never Pleasant you have to
defend rook on f3 but again now the rock
is pinned you place the king and g2 not
a very enjoyable thing to do Queen to d5
by Carlsen we have worked to e2 now
adding protection to the second rank and
also not allowing the pond to advance
any further we have a 5 by Carlsen h4
and now a capture zombie for a capture
some before and rock to a 2
Petrosyan doesn't have time to capture
on g5 as the rockin e2 is hanging so he
has to deal with this
he plays Queen to he want to protect the
rook rook captures Queen captures and
rook the other row comes to a8 now
threatening rock rock coming to a to
winning the Queen here so again
Petrosyan doesn't have time to actually
capture the bishop and g5 king to h3 was
played getting the king gonna go out of
the way but it doesn't really help black
rook - 8 - what a tempo on the Queen we
have Queen to f1 and now comes eetu what
a temp on the Queen of course if the
Queen moves to a weird square like g2
then e1 will come with a promotion of a
queen so Queen to f2 he does have to
protect he won but now simply Queen to
e6 by Carlsen and in this position and
the Armenian Grandmaster Tegel Ivanovich
petrosyan resigned the game as there is
really nothing he can do in this
position and this is it's quite a
beautiful position if you play something
like King to g2 simply he won Queen and
you don't really have a choice here your
queen is under attack
it'll be captured if you play any move
let's say D 7th and then Carlsen could
even make a little joke with Queen - h1
check King characters now Queen to h3
check King to rook a1 check Queen has
the block and now Bishop to e3 check
rook has to capture King has nowhere to
go
rope CalPERS and the rook captures on f1
this is checkmate so a wonderful game
between Carlson and Armenian Grandmaster
Tigran lavona which petrosyan after
after that game against the circuit
current across and said in an interview
after that game he really felt that he
had a chance to win this tournament and
he he really did win it to two whole
points ahead of the field after kirkin
then he defeated King Lear and he
defeated Anton gorev of what is love
artemiev and Diggle in the one which
Petrosyan here he then drew against
Levon Aronian
and it was it was a great day for Magnus
Carlsen today yesterday he said he was
lucky but as I said there is no luck in
chess a lock favors the strong magnets
calls and showed plenty of times he is a
strong player so no no need to call it
lucky but it was a it was kind of
refreshing you're seeing Magnus cross
and humble now and then so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it once
again congratulations to Magnus Carlsen
for winning this amazing event the world
blitz championship he almost did the
same thing in the rapid championship but
it just wasn't his day yesterday so yeah
I would like to thank our - Chi Chi
Annan and Matthew Haines for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
- really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
both will be from the world blitz
championship and again feel free to use
hashtag suggestions to suggest your
favourite game from the world rapid and
bliss championship I will probably cover
these games for the next couple of days
I still haven't covered that game
between I think it's from I think it's I
think it's a job a la game but can't
really be sure I don't know who he was
playing against I think it's viddler
versus Jabba where sweedler
finishes the game with the black pieces
would Knight to b3 check but I have to
check it it was an amazing game so again
feel free to use it suggest games I will
go through all the comments and if it's
an interesting game I will definitely
show it so thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon